il ya maintenant plus de téléphones
cellulaires que d'humains sur la planète
soit plus de 7 milliards
jamais dans l'histoire les humains d'en
développer une relation de symbiose
aussi rapidement et aussi complètement
avec un objet électronique pourtant très
peu de recherches scientifiques
explorent le lien entre cette nouvelle
dépendance et la santé humaine
bonsoir michel bonsoir c'est une
première étude là qui a mesuré l'impact
de la séparation de jeunes utilisateurs
avec leur téléphone ça c'est surprenant
les résultats c'est assez surprenant
c'est une étude université du missouri
alors ils ont ils ont démontré que ce
petit appareil là si on sépare sa des
jeunes
ils développent des problèmes
psychologiques et physiologiques
alors oui effectivement ça peut sembler
surprenant mais je pense que tout le
monde sait que nos jeunes sont accrochés
aux jeunes les moins jeunes également
également les journalistes alors au
stade où on en est rendu on prétend ces
chercheurs le prétendent qu'il est mieux
de l'avoir avec soi si on doit faire un
travail intellectuel
alors comment est ce qu'ils ont réussi à
démontrer sa à ben c'est tout simple en
fait c'est vous souvenez quand on était
jeunes on joue et on aimait les moins
jeunes également au jeu du mont cacher
alors on leur a demandé de jouer à ça
avec leur téléphone est là on l'a fait
sonner il n'avait pas le droit d'y
toucher
moisson jouer après ça on a enlevé le
téléphone et là on a continué à le faire
ce n'est mise avait pas le droit d'y
toucher
et là soudainement on a découvert plein
de choses allons voir ça sur le tableau
alors on a vu que le rythme cardiaque à
monter que leur pression artérielle a
monté et dans des tests psychologiques
par la suite on a vu que ça causait de
l'anxiété et des sensations désagréables
lorsque le téléphone était loin et
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas y avoir accès
contrairement à continuer sur exact et
qu'est ce que ça nous disent sur leur
comportement ce une première étude mais
quand même on doit avoir certaines
conclusions
oui à des conclusions bon on parle que
le téléphone est maintenant vendu
un objet de syndicats ou ce que ça fait
partie du mois c'est comme ça que les
psychologues décrire ça on sait que les
cyber dépendance a été bien démontré
avec l'ordinateur là on se rend compte
que ces objets mobiles là ont également
cet impact
bon évidemment il ya d'autres études qui
démontrent quand même que ce petit
appareil peut avoir certains aspects
certains effets bénéfiques sur la santé
par exemple louis tank à l'avoir avec
nous il ya plein d'applications
maintenant qu'ils existent pour la diète
pour l'exercice alors une méta-analyse
de 14 bonnes études sur plus de 1300
personnes a démontré que sur une période
de 3 à 6 mois on peut perdre environ 1,4
kg soit trois livres ça peut paraître
assez peu quand même bien sûr une
population élargie on est en pleine
épidémie d'obésité de diabète de manque
d'exercice on prétend que si on les
utilise comme il faut pour l'ensemble la
population peut faire baisser la
mortalité mais ni les coûts associés à
sa naturellement mais bon il ya des bons
côtés des mauvais côtés à l'objet il ya
aussi les micro ondes ça ferait l'objet
d'un autre de nos débats et d'autres
notre chronique on voit